[Music]
you roll out of bed and leap eight
meters across your underground habitat
their gray water from your sink drains
into a small greenhouse where your
vegetables grow after suiting up you
head through a transport chute to
inspect the generator outside it's pitch
black
just as it's been for the last 12 days
this isn't some post-apocalyptic
scenario it's just another day of life
on the moon and with the European Space
Agency's idea to establish a functioning
moon camp by the 2020s that day may be
closer than we think of course living on
the moon won't be easy the camp
envisioned is not so much a village as
an inhabited research base similar to
those in places like Antarctica but
there are far greater obstacles to
living on the moon than just cold
weather the biggest is cosmic radiation
unlike the earth the moon has no
atmosphere and no magnetic field a
person on its surface can receive over
400 times the maximum safe dosage of
heavy ion radiation enough to be fatal
within 10 hours even in a space suit the
first step would likely involve robots
and 3d printers constructing covered
habitats from lunar soil
or building shelters inside caves formed
by lava tubes from the moon's volcanic
past but what would the inhabitants live
on supplies would need to be transported
from Earth at first growing plants
requires greenhouse soil and air rich
and carbon dioxide a gas that's rare on
the moon but could be synthesized from
recycled materials a water treatment
plant could be supplied by ice mined
from the polar regions
using a specialized drill that can bore
two meters beneath the lunar surface
friendly bacteria and viruses necessary
to the human microbiome and immune
system would also have to be imported or
synthesized on-site and lunar
inhabitants would have to exercise four
hours a day to maintain bone and muscle
mass that's because the moon's gravity
is just one sixth that of the earth and
the everyday strain of working against
gravity is part of what keeps our bodies
healthy it might seem strange to go to
all this trouble to build a base on a
dead Rock we've already visited but
NASA's Apollo missions only explored a
small portions of the moon we've made
many discoveries since then such as ice
near the poles and particles of solar
wind gases that date back billions of
years they collectively show that the
moon has much more to teach us about the
history of our solar system a radio
telescope on its far side could observe
the cosmos shielded from the Earth's
electromagnetic interference and the
lunar surface is rich in minerals like
silicon aluminium and magnesium creating
great economic potential for mining but
the biggest benefit of the moon camp may
not lie on the moon but beyond it with
the nearest possibly habitable world
light-years away and the International
Space Station to be retired in about a
decade a moon base would be our first
football towards becoming an
interplanetary species and proposals
such as the deep-space gateway envision
launching future missions from lunar
orbit the smaller gravitational pole
would require less fuel to overcome
allowing for larger ships and more
meanwhile the base on the surface could
serve as a testing ground for future
space operations a refueling station and
a supply depot all in one with Europe
Russia China and the u.s. expressing
interest in the project the moon camp
may come to involve the space agencies
of all major nations as well as private
companies within a few decades the moon
may be bustling with mining operations
research stations and tourist routes
alongside a Construction Yard under an
orbiting space port we may have already
visited the moon but now we're closer
than ever to making it part of
humanity's home keep trekking through
the vast reaches of outer space with
this playlist
[Music]